well
hello what changes today in 3 gonzález with
your informative game for Thursday
March 25th premium straight experience
is looking to hire to fill
various positions for that reason there will be
a job fair today to look for
people who want to work
full time between the positions of  work
are on security guard 20 to the
public and more the fair will begin at 2
in the afternoon and will last only until 4 in
the afternoon
among other news the
vaccination clinic located inside the ciecem in
north las vegas is offering
night appointments as well  en there will be appointments
available until 8 pm to
schedule a baby visit at equis nl
dot com or call 1 800 4 0 10 946
officers belonging to
the clark county district police department
participate in a contest where they
must eat waffles for a
fundraiser for your team out of every 95 k9
work with officers at some
point this year two more dogs form  ron
part of this team
these funds will help with the
training of the team and the sensors
inside the patrol cars it is located very
handsome near maryland and flamingo is in
charge of organizing this event now
we go to see the weather forecast
we will have temperatures in the high 60s
for today with some winds of 30
miles per hour in the southwest of the valley
however warmer temperatures are expected
for the weekend
around 70 and up to 80 degrees have
a nice day between andrés gonzález this
was your brief news briefing  now in
Spanish
[Music]